check emails during downtime
so i'm here doing uh one of my least
favorite activities in the world
grocery shopping all right
and i've been experimenting with
checking emails and i used to do
i'd block off a chunks 90 minutes a day
of doing emails and instead i thought
you know what when i'm doing stuff that
i'm i hate doing like grocery shopping
or standing in line or
waiting for you know
the department of motor vehicles to give
me a new license plate all of the boring
stuff that we have to do in our
day-to-day lives that's when i open my
phone and check my email
so i got a lot of email done here uh
wall grocery shopping
and i've i've segmented it out so i have
two main things that i do i have a
folder for all my
main customers and my staff and my team
and my family
and then a folder for everybody else and
i do a daily check of the important
folder and everybody else folder
you get a response now when i'm doing my
grocery shopping
so try it out
check the email when
you're doing boring stuff and that gives
you more time during the day to focus on
important projects in your business
you want to see what i'm buying here's
my
cart
and my favorite thing
my favorite purchase
are these brown rice
tomato and basil crackers from triscuits
okay i'm causing a ruckus here i'm
taking up space in a line so that's it
hope you guys enjoy
you